It's all right. You're the two-time best presentation winner of C++ now, so... Well, they are named after him. The Tony Awards. Are they called the Tony Awards? Unofficially. I did not know that. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 24 recorded on May 6 2021. My name is Connor and on today's episode it's just me interviewing Ben Dean and Tony van Aerd on the fourth day of C++ now 2021. I also want to quickly apologize for my echoey poor audio in this episode. I just moved into a new apartment and did not realize how much echo there was, so I will be sure to fix this for episode 25, but for this episode,
没关系。你现在是两届 C++ Now 最佳演讲奖得主了，所以……嗯，托尼奖（Tony Awards）是以他命名的。它们叫托尼奖吗？非正式地说是。我以前不知道。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 24 期，录制于 2021 年 5 月 6 日。我是 Connor，在今天的节目中，只有我一个人在 C++ Now 2021 大会的第四天采访 Ben Dean 和 Tony van Aerd。我还要快速为本期节目中回声严重、音质不佳的情况道歉。我刚搬进新公寓，没意识到回声这么大，我一定会确保在第 25 期解决这个问题，但对于这一期，
you'll have to bear with me. Tuning in live from C++ Now 2021. We were supposed to have four people here. We currently have two. I'm here with Ben Dean, whose voice you may have heard in the pre-intro, and Tony may or may not be showing up. I'm not sure, Ben, for those of our listeners that don't know you, do you want to introduce yourself? Sure. I am probably known in the C++ community for a few of my talks, which I've done in the last five or so years at C++ Now and CppCon. I worked in the games industry for
你得忍受一下了。正在从 C++ Now 2021 直播。我们本应有四个人在这里。目前只有两个。我和 Ben Dean 在一起，你可能在片头前听到过他的声音，Tony 可能会出现，也可能不会。我不确定，Ben，对于那些不认识你的听众，你想自我介绍一下吗？当然。我可能在 C++ 社区因为过去五年左右在 C++ Now 和 CppCon 上做过的几次演讲而闻名。我在游戏行业工作了
20-odd years, and I now work in the finance industry. I've been something which just went out of my head. I've been on CppCast a couple of times. Yep. Probably, well, so yeah, I mentioned this.
20 多年，现在在金融行业工作。我曾经做过某件事，但我刚才忘了。我上过几次 CppCast。是的。可能，嗯，是的，我提到了这一点。
I'm not sure how we're going to cut this up or if it's going to be mentioned twice. So yeah, the reason why we were trying to get both Ben and Tony because they're quite well known, I think, at C++ now. Ben, in both, correct me if I get the years wrong, 2017 and 2018, 2018, I believe, was the talk with Jason Turner. You won best talk of the conference, or was that reversed? Yeah, 2017 was the concept for all the things talk,
我不确定我们该怎么剪辑，或者它是否会被提到两次。所以，是的，我们试图同时邀请 Ben 和 Tony 的原因是因为我认为他们在 C++ Now 非常出名。Ben，在——如果我年份记错了请纠正我——2017 年和 2018 年，我相信 2018 年是和 Jason Turner 的那场演讲。你赢得了会议的最佳演讲，还是反过来？是的，2017 年是“为所有事物使用概念（concepts for all the things）”的演讲，
which was Jason and me having a lot of fun. 2018 was my declarative style talk. Yeah, easy to use, hard to misuse. That's probably one of my top five favorite talks of all time. It was the genesis of my love for the immediately invoked Lambda expression, which I'm not sure if I've mentioned it on this podcast, but I had seen it before, but this speaks to sort of like where you are in your learning curve.
那是 Jason 和我玩得很开心的一次。2018 年是我的声明式风格演讲。是的，易于使用，难以误用。那可能是我有史以来最喜欢的五大演讲之一。它是我热爱立即调用 Lambda 表达式（IIFE）的起源，我不确定我是否在播客中提到过，但我之前见过它，但这说明了你处于学习曲线的什么位置。
Like it didn't hit me. Like I didn't, I think before that really appreciate what expressions versus statements were. Anyways, it was in that talk that I saw that and I was like, oh my goodness, this is amazing. Because at that point, I think I'd known that other languages like Kotlin have if expressions, which are quite nice. I think Rust has the same thing now. Right. And now you have been very prolific in your speaking career and you've given names to some of these things like the initialize then modify anti-pattern. Yeah. Well, I'm not sure. It's really just like I realized after the fact that Jason had basically given a quasi same
就像它没有击中我一样。我想在那之前我并没有真正理解表达式与语句的区别。总之，在那场演讲中我看到了它，我就想，天哪，这太棒了。因为在那时，我想我已经知道像 Kotlin 这样的其他语言有 if 表达式，它们非常好。我想 Rust 现在也有同样的东西。没错。而且你现在的演讲生涯非常多产，你还为其中一些东西命名，比如“初始化后修改（initialize then modify）”反模式。是的。嗯，我不确定。我只是在事后意识到 Jason 基本上给出了一个几乎相同的
version of that talk. So I've given a talk called my least favorite anti-pattern where I termed ITM. And then after that, and it's all just about whenever you initialize a variable and then immediately modify it, if you can avoid that, like there's some cases where you're writing an algorithm with a for loop
版本的演讲。所以我做了一个名为“我最不喜欢的反模式”的演讲，我将其称为 ITM。在那之后，它只是关于每当你初始化一个变量然后立即修改它时，如果你能避免这种情况——比如有些情况下你正在编写一个带有 for 循环的算法，
in it, which is not a raw for loop. It's just a for loop. And you're obviously going to have variables that you're, you're modifying, but. But in the greater scope of things, a lot of times it's unnecessary. And if you can sort of try to avoid that pattern, I think it leads to more readable declarative code. And then I ended up watching Jason Turner's, and also too, we've mentioned Jason's name. I assume like 80% of our audience knows, but Jason is also a speaker um and he's a c++ uh trainer and um he is the co-host of probably the like the premier c++ podcast cpp cast which
那不是原始的 for 循环。它只是一个 for 循环。你显然会有你正在修改的变量，但是。但在更大的范围内，很多时候这是不必要的。如果你能尽量避免这种模式，我认为它会带来更具可读性的声明式代码。然后我最终看了 Jason Turner 的演讲，而且，我们也提到了 Jason 的名字。我假设 80% 的听众都知道，但 Jason 也是一位演讲者，他是一位 C++ 培训师，他是可能首屈一指的 C++ 播客 CppCast 的联合主持人，
is one of my favorite podcasts as well jason and rob jason gave a good talk at c++ now a couple of was it yesterday or the day before yeah it was um what was the title of the talk because i've renamed it in my head to a different title the worst best practices yes yeah i i after the fact it said it's uh the longer title is probably uh jason turner's 20-year history in c plus plus and how to self-publish a book um right because because he sort of talks about that but yeah that was probably one of the better talks i so i guess yeah we're hopping all over here but anyway so to wrap up the last bit well this is what adsp is though uh jason basically gave a
这也是我最喜欢的播客之一。Jason 和 Rob。Jason 在 C++ Now 做了一场很棒的演讲，是昨天还是前天？是的，是……演讲的标题是什么？因为我在脑海中把它重命名为另一个标题：最糟糕的最佳实践。是的，是的，事后看来，它说的是……更长的标题可能是“Jason Turner 的 20 年 C++ 历史以及如何自出版一本书”，对吧？因为他确实谈到了这一点，但是的，那可能是更好的演讲之一。所以我猜，是的，我们在这里跳来跳去，但无论如何，总结一下最后一点……嗯，这就是 ADSP 的风格……Jason 基本上做了一个
talk on uh best practices and then while watching it because i i never saw it live i was watching it on youtube i was like half of his talk is basically just a different statement of what I'm saying. And so now I'm, I'm basically just plagiarizing, which is what I do in all my talks. Anyways, that's a good, that's a good way to give good talks is just find other good talks and then cut those all up. Yes, I've, I do the same in the sense that, well, I've sort of learned that it's almost not possible to repeat a good idea enough. Like it always bears repetition. It always bears another talk, which brings a little bit extra. At the end of the day, there's a lot of us who are speaking about things like strong typing, declarative code, expressive code. We all have our own takes on it. And it feels like,
关于最佳实践的演讲，当观看它时——因为我从未现场看过，我是在 YouTube 上看的——我就想，他的一半演讲基本上只是我所说内容的另一种陈述。所以现在我基本上只是在剽窃，这就是我在所有演讲中所做的。总之，这是一个做高质量演讲的好方法，就是找到其他好的演讲，然后把它们剪辑在一起。是的，我也一样，因为我已经了解到，重复一个好主意几乎是不可能的。它总是值得重复。它总是值得再做一次演讲，带来一点额外的东西。归根结底，我们中有很多人在谈论强类型、声明式代码、表达性代码。我们都有自己的看法。感觉就像，
you know, if you look, if I look back at the talks I've given, it feels to me like I've said the same thing multiple times. I'm sure it feels that way to a lot of people who give talks that they sort of rehashing the same ideas. But, you know, if they're good ideas, and I think they are, then repetition is warranted. Yeah. And it's, that's the thing, right? Is people, when you're giving a talk, at least this is my experience from both giving and watching, is that the talk is going to hit people different ways, depending on where they are in their learning journey. I think a lot of my talks, if you're just starting out, it's going to be, you know, over some of the folks in the audience head.
你知道，如果你回顾我做过的演讲，我觉得我多次说过同样的话。我相信对于许多做演讲的人来说，他们也会觉得自己在重弹旧调。但是，如果它们是好主意，而且我认为它们是，那么重复是有道理的。是的。这就是重点，对吧？当你在做演讲时，至少这是我从演讲和观看中得到的经验，演讲会以不同的方式触动人们，取决于他们处于学习旅程的哪个阶段。我认为我的很多演讲，如果你刚开始，那对观众中的一些人来说可能太深奥了。
And then for other folks, I'm just repeating things that they learned 10 years ago. And it's like, oh, this is sort of entertaining. But from an educational perspective on an individual basis for them, they haven't learned much. And then there's another proportion where it just sort of blows their mind and it opens their eyes. And there are, that's the thing is like Phil, I sort of have told this anecdote before is that Phil Nash gave a talk called Functional C++ for Fun and Profit back in like 2016 or 2017, which covered a lot of the same themes in your declarative talk, easy to use, hard to misuse. But when I watched Phil's talk, I wasn't ready to accept everything.
而对于其他人，我只是在重复他们 10 年前学到的东西。这就像，哦，这有点意思。但从个人的教育角度来看，他们并没有学到太多。然后还有另一部分人，这让他们大开眼界。这就是重点，就像 Phil，我之前讲过这个轶事，Phil Nash 在 2016 年或 2017 年做了一个名为“函数式 C++：为了乐趣和利润”的演讲，涵盖了你声明式演讲中的许多相同主题，易于使用，难以误用。但当我观看 Phil 的演讲时，我还没有准备好接受一切。
Like I just, I didn't have enough of like a knowledge foundation. And so anyways, that speaks to the repeatability. The other thing I see and I sort of come to terms with is the fact that nobody owns an idea. And so when I'm making a talk when i'm having ideas about what to put into a talk often i make the talk and then i see like other talks maybe even that are coming up around the same time that are talking about what seemed like exactly the same
就像我没有足够的知识基础。所以无论如何，这说明了可重复性。我看到的另一件事，我也已经接受了，那就是没有人拥有一个想法。所以当我准备演讲时，当我想到要在演讲中放入什么内容时，我经常会做这个演讲，然后我看到其他可能在同一时间出现的演讲，它们谈论的似乎是完全相同的
idea and you know there's no like i, nobody owns an idea. So someone else could totally independently create a talk which has a large overlap. I used to worry about that. Now I see that as a sign of like, okay, if other people are having these same ideas, then it means probably that the zeitgeist of C++ is ready for this. Like, it's a good sign, not a sign of like plagiarism or other people scooping me or anything like that. Right. And that's exactly what happened with one of the three, the girdle, Turing, and Church, right? They all came up with the same idea.
想法，你知道，没有人拥有一个想法。所以其他人完全可以独立地创建一个有很大重叠的演讲。我过去很担心这一点。现在我把它看作是一个信号，就像，好吧，如果其他人也有这些想法，那么这意味着 C++ 的时代精神可能已经准备好迎接它了。这是一个好迹象，而不是剽窃或别人抢先我一步的迹象。没错。这正是那三个——哥德尔、图灵和丘奇——发生的事情，对吧？他们都想到了同一个主意。
Oh, right. Yeah. Back in the, what is it, 30s, early 40s. And that was the funny thing, right? Because I'm going to mess up. Or maybe you, do you know the story of which uh disagreed with one of the others and then like i believe it was girdle who took a lot of convincing yeah and and when he found out that his uh whatever statement of the problem was the same as i think it was turing's he said well
哦，对。是的。回到……是什么时候，30 年代，40 年代初。那很有趣，对吧？因为我会搞砸。或者也许你，你知道那个故事吗，其中一个不同意另一个，然后我相信是哥德尔，他需要很多说服工作。是的，当他发现他的……无论什么问题陈述与我想是图灵的一样时，他说，好吧，
obviously i'm wrong then um because he's definitely wrong so if ours is the same thing i must also be wrong and then it took him a while to realize that oh oh, no, Turing was Turing was correct. And I'm also correct. And they're the same thing, which I thought that's a funny thing that first you think they're different. Then you think they're the same. Then because you think his is wrong, you must also be. Yeah. I mean, what you said about, you know, a talk just hitting someone at the right time in their learning journey is totally rings true with me. Also, it's the case that, you know, you can watch a talk and kind of not get all of it. But having watched it later on, when you watch another talk, that's when another talk can actually like put a light bulb on your head about the first talk. Yeah. Yeah. There's tons of dotted lines between,
显然我错了。因为他肯定是错的，所以如果我们的东西是一样的，那我也一定是错的。然后他花了一段时间才意识到，哦，不，图灵是正确的。我也是正确的。它们是一样的，我觉得这很有趣，起初你认为它们不同。然后你认为它们是一样的。然后因为你认为他是错的，所以你一定也是。是的。我的意思是，你所说的关于一场演讲在学习旅程的正确时间触动某人，这对我来说完全是真的。同样的情况是，你知道，你可以看一场演讲，却不能完全理解它。但后来，当你观看另一场演讲时，那场演讲实际上可以让你对第一场演讲产生顿悟。是的。是的。之间有无数的虚线，
well, I mean, for those that haven't attended the conference, Tony Van Eerd, who may or may not join in a couple minutes, he might be working on his lightning talk for later today. He gave a keynote yesterday where he showed a bunch of dotted lines um in between his solid revisited talk and what were all the talks he mentioned um uh phil nash's talk um close eagle burger i think i'm pronouncing that correctly i apologize um and then kevlin henney's given a solid talk as well um and he and then he went on to mention a bunch of other talks like rich hickeys. Who's the creator of closure. He has a famous look.
嗯，我的意思是，对于那些没有参加会议的人，Tony Van Eerd，他可能会在几分钟内加入，他可能正在为今天晚些时候的闪电演讲做准备。他昨天做了一个主题演讲，展示了一堆虚线，在他之前的 Solid 回顾演讲和他提到的所有演讲之间……Phil Nash 的演讲，Close Eagleburger，我想我发音正确，我道歉……然后 Kevlin Henney 也做了一个 Solid 演讲，然后他继续提到了许多其他演讲，比如 Rich Hickey 的。他是 Clojure 的创造者。他有一个著名的观点。
There's the man, the myth, the legend, a wild Tony appears. We were just talking about your keynote, Tony. And also too, do you even,
那个人，那个神话，那个传奇，一只野生的 Tony 出现了。我们刚才正在谈论你的主题演讲，Tony。还有，你甚至……
do we just assume all the listeners know who you are? There might be a few like Swift developers that. No, no one knows who I am that's what i assume that's not true well i've come to yes through working in the games industry i've come to uh take this take this tack as well all right so tony you should i guess briefly introduce yourself to the uh either c++ developers that um have watched any talks online, because I assume yours has got to be like in the first five talks that people watch. Well, if I had to, if you're telling me I have to introduce myself, then let's just say everyone knows me.
我们是否只是假设所有听众都知道你是谁？可能有一些像 Swift 开发人员……不，没人知道我是谁，这是我的假设。那不是真的。好吧，通过在游戏行业工作，我也采取了这种策略。好吧，Tony，我想你应该向那些看过在线演讲的 C++ 开发人员简要介绍一下你自己，因为我假设你的演讲一定在人们观看的前五个演讲之列。好吧，如果我必须，如果你告诉我我必须介绍我自己，那么我们就说大家都认识我。
I'm on the committee, C++ committee. I've worked at interesting places like Adobe, BlackBerry. I still find BlackBerry was an interesting place. Small places, big places. I know at Christie, I do projection mapping, which is really cool stuff. And yeah, I give talks every now and then. People like them, so I keep doing it. Yes, if you haven't seen postmodern C++ or words of wisdom, those are also two of my favorite talks of all time. And I think I've seen the postmodern one like three or four times now, because you gave it once in C++ now, once in CppCon where it started to rhyme.
我在委员会，C++ 委员会。我在 Adobe、BlackBerry 等有趣的地方工作过。我仍然觉得 BlackBerry 是一个有趣的地方。小地方，大地方。我知道在 Christie，我做投影映射，这真的很酷。是的，我偶尔会做演讲。人们喜欢它们，所以我继续做。是的，如果你还没看过“后现代 C++”或“智慧之言”，那也是我个人最喜欢的两场演讲。我想我已经看过那场后现代演讲三四次了，因为你在 C++ Now 做过一次，在 CppCon 做过一次，在那里它开始押韵了。
And then I think you also gave it at the Prague meetup at the last in-person C++ ISO meeting. Yeah. Rest in peace to. Three times. And it's different every time. And, you know, you got to watch the next one. Then you can put piece together the secret message that I've left behind
然后我想你还在最后一次面对面的 C++ ISO 会议的布拉格聚会上做过。是的，安息吧。三次。而且每次都不一样。而且，你知道，你必须看下一个。然后你可以拼凑出我留下的秘密信息
and all the variations. So I guess, should we talk or how are folks, how are you liking virtual c++ now what are the best talks how did you you so ben has not spoken this year but uh tony did give a keynote called solid revisited that we mentioned before him joining what are how are people feeling how was how was giving your keynote well you know what that's the the thing. I have no idea. Like, to be honest, I didn't want to do virtual anything, right? Because it just feels like giving talks, I don't know if people realize giving talks is actually hard, right? It takes effort. And it really drains you. And then at the end, though, you're like, oh, this was really cool. This was fun. It was worth all the pain that you went through to do it. And it's usually a good experience. But this time, it's all virtual. You don't feel the audience. You don't know what's going on. And then it's over. And you're like, huh? I have no idea what
以及所有的变体。所以我想，我们应该谈谈，或者大家觉得虚拟的 C++ Now 怎么样，最好的演讲是什么，你是怎么……所以 Ben 今年没有演讲，但 Tony 确实做了一个我们提到的名为“Solid 回顾”的主题演讲。人们感觉如何？做你的主题演讲感觉如何？嗯，你知道吗，这就是重点。我不知道。老实说，我不想做任何虚拟的东西，对吧？因为这感觉就像做演讲，我不知道人们是否意识到做演讲实际上很难，对吧？它需要努力。它真的会让你精疲力竭。然后最后，你会觉得，哦，这真的很酷。这很有趣。它值得你经历的所有痛苦。而且这通常是一种很好的体验。但这一次，它是全虚拟的。你感觉不到观众。你不知道发生了什么。然后它结束了。你就想，哈？我不知道发生了什么，对吧？
happened, right? But C++ Now is like one of my favorite conferences. So I wanted to make sure we had a good year this year. I thought I had no idea if there was going to be lots of talks or hardly any talks or what was going to happen to it. So I'm like, I'm going to put in a talk. I wasn't planning on doing a keynote, but I thought I'll do a talk to my part, show up. But now I haven't seen any talks since then, because as is tradition, I see no talks before my talk because I'm too busy doing my slides. And then I was going to, I've just been busy today, as I forgot even that I was going to talk to you guys. I was busy doing stuff. I'm going to see Lisa's talk, right? Lisa Lippincott is my favorite speaker, maybe possibly my top, one of my top five, you know, one of my favorite
但 C++ Now 是我最喜欢的会议之一。所以我确保我们今年有一个好的一年。我想我不知道会有很多演讲还是几乎没有演讲，或者它会发生什么。所以我说，我要做一个演讲。我没打算做主题演讲，但我认为我会做一个演讲，尽我的一份力，出现。但现在我从那以后没看过任何演讲，因为按照传统，我在我的演讲之前不看任何演讲，因为我太忙于做幻灯片了。然后我打算……我今天一直很忙，因为我甚至忘了我要和你们谈话。我忙于做事情。我要去看 Lisa 的演讲，对吧？Lisa Lippincott 是我最喜欢的演讲者，可能是我前五名，你知道，我最喜欢的
speakers. I love the stuff that she talks about. It's a little, some people find it a little more theoretical and whatnot or whatever. It's kind of very foundational talks of how, what is a function? What is a program? But I love it. Just love it.
演讲者之一。我喜欢她谈论的东西。它有点……有些人觉得它更理论化等等。这是关于什么是函数、什么是程序的非常基础的演讲。但我喜欢它。就是喜欢它。
So I'm going to go to her talk. That's tomorrow. And that's been my, I had at least two talks circled. I wanted to see Barry's talk on ranges and stuff. He was comparing different languages. But we were all sitting around at one of those little...
所以我打算去听她的演讲。那是明天。那是我的……我至少圈出了两个演讲。我想看 Barry 关于范围（ranges）等的演讲。他正在比较不同的语言。但我们都坐在那些小……
That was during the... yesterday when we all ended up at a virtual table. We were in the hallway track. In the hallway track, yeah, which has always been the best track of C++ now. So I didn't see barry's talk yet but i will watch it later it's good i watched it last night yeah uh yeah it he did a really good job comparing c and c plus and rust and d and he sort of put them on a functionality versus uh complexity curve i think it was a very sort of good comparison and breakdown it had the uh from finance i think it's called the efficient frontier
那是在……昨天我们最终坐在一个虚拟桌子旁的时候。我们在走廊轨道（hallway track）上，是的，这一直是 C++ Now 最好的轨道。所以我还没看 Barry 的演讲，但我以后会看的。它很好，我昨晚看了。是的，他做得很好，比较了 C、C++、Rust 和 D，他把它们放在了功能与复杂性曲线上，我认为这是一个非常好的比较和分解。它有……从金融领域，我想它被称为有效前沿（efficient frontier），
there's a sort of curved line and he put we won't spoil it but d and c plus plus and rust get ranked and then we can spoil the fact that java was below the efficient frontier so you know they there was a time when you look at their iterator right and it's it doesn't feel like an iterated way we know iterators it really is just it's it's the it is the collection right it's it's their iterators feel it's where you pull the value out of and and it's like is there another one and then you get the next value and and uh like our c plus plus what eric did with sentinels right with ranges and he said you know begin end iterator let's make the end not really an iterator it can be a sentinel now it doesn't have to be an iterator it is just a big hack like that is a hack it's a beautiful beautiful hack right it's like now be an iterator. It is just a big hack. Like that is a hack. It's a beautiful, beautiful hack, right? It's like now your end iterator, if it was,
有一条曲线，他把……我们不会剧透，但 D、C++ 和 Rust 得到了排名，然后我们可以剧透一下 Java 低于有效前沿的事实，所以你知道，他们曾经有一段时间看他们的迭代器，它感觉不像我们所知的迭代器，它真的是……它就是集合，对吧？它的迭代器感觉像是你从中取出值的地方，然后就像，还有另一个吗？然后你得到下一个值，就像我们的 C++，Eric 用哨兵（sentinels）所做的那样，对吧？用范围，他说，你知道 begin、end 迭代器，让我们让 end 不再是一个真正的迭代器，它现在可以是一个哨兵，它不必是一个迭代器，它只是一个大黑客，那是一个黑客，这是一个美丽、美丽的黑客，对吧？就像现在是迭代器。它只是一个大黑客。就像那是一个黑客。这是一个美丽、美丽的黑客，对吧？就像现在你的 end 迭代器，如果它是，
because people used to do this in the past where your iterator had to be special, right? It's not really the end. It's just has a flag inside of it to say, when I do the comparison, I will do the real check for end. And that was also a hack. Eric has made that hack, you know, he stamped it as official now and it's great. and that was also a hack. Eric has made that hack, you know, he's stamped
因为人们过去常这样做，你的迭代器必须是特殊的，对吧？它不是真正的 end。它只是里面有一个标志来说，当我进行比较时，我会进行真正的 end 检查。那也是一个黑客。Eric 已经把那个黑客做成了，你知道，他现在把它盖章为官方的了，这很棒。那也是一个黑客。Eric 已经把那个黑客做成了，你知道，他盖章
it as official now and it's great but I wonder if it's all I've run into this before that two iterators is wrong, just not the right way to go. So that's why I wanted to see Barry's talk. Like
它现在是官方的，这很棒，但我不知道它是否……我之前遇到过这种情况，两个迭代器是错误的，只是不是正确的前进方式。这就是为什么我想看 Barry 的演讲。就像
in fact, like when you have, the example is when you have an infinite range right i've got all the numbers right now we can now do that with with c++ ranges this range never ends it's got an end iterator but it's a fake iterator and and uh you know if you're doing a zip or something else you can you can zip infinite numbers with a finite vector and now you've got a number for each item in the vector or whatever you want, right? That end iterator is just fake. The whole thing is a lie.
事实上，当你拥有时，例子是当你拥有一个无限范围时，对吧？我现在拥有所有的数字，我们现在可以用 C++ 范围来做到这一点，这个范围永远不会结束，它有一个 end 迭代器，但它是一个假的迭代器，而且……你知道，如果你正在做 zip 或其他东西，你可以用一个有限的向量来 zip 无限的数字，现在你为向量中的每个项目都有一个数字，或者任何你想要的，对吧？那个 end 迭代器只是假的。整个事情都是一个谎言。
So why do we force our iteration in our ranges to have a begin end when that's a lie, right? It should be one object that you ask, are we at the end yet? But we wanted to fit it in with what we already had, and so it works really well. It is. It's really good. But it's also, you know, I wondered,
所以为什么我们强迫我们的范围迭代有一个 begin end，当那是一个谎言时，对吧？它应该是一个你询问的对象，我们到尽头了吗？但我们想把它与我们已经拥有的东西结合起来，所以它工作得很好。它是。它真的很好。但它也是，你知道，我想知道，
like, maybe we shouldn't have done it this way. Maybe we should have. But I think if Eric had done the new ranges any other way, it wouldn't have happened. So it's the right way to do things. There's my hot take. My hot take. Did you need a hot take? That's a good things. There's my hot take. My hot take. Did you need a hot take?
就像，也许我们不应该这样做。也许我们应该。但我认为如果 Eric 用任何其他方式做新的范围，它就不会发生。所以这是做事情的正确方式。这是我的热点观点。我的热点观点。你需要一个热点观点吗？那是好东西。这是我的热点观点。我的热点观点。你需要一个热点观点吗？
That's a good one. It's good for the ratings. Sentinels are a hack. That's what Tony says. But there are some surprises there. You're right. I remember playing with ranges the first time and getting that sort of surprise because, yeah, a half-infinite range, like natural like natural numbers can be it has a
那是一个很好的观点。这对收视率有好处。哨兵是一个黑客。这就是 Tony 说的。但那里有一些惊喜。你是对的。我记得第一次玩范围并得到那种惊喜，因为，是的，半无限范围，像自然数，它可以有一个
bi-directional iterator right because because we know how to move backwards and forwards but you can't reverse it yeah so so you know that intuition kind of gets upended like we expect to be able to reverse something with bi-directional iterator but if you don't have a start place you can't you can reverse it you just can only you can't start from the beginning elements of it in reverse but there's nowhere to start and say reverse this it just take you a long time yeah anyways so those are the two talks you were looking forward to one you'll still get to see because lisa's is this we're recording this on thursday lisa's talk is on friday barry's was yesterday there's probably more that i also wanted to see
双向迭代器，对吧？因为我们知道如何向后和向前移动，但你不能反转它。是的，所以……你知道那种直觉被颠覆了，就像我们期望能够反转带有双向迭代器的东西，但如果你没有起点，你就不能，你可以反转它，你只是不能从它的开头元素反向开始，但没有地方可以开始并说反转这个，它只是需要很长时间。是的，无论如何，这些就是你期待的两场演讲，一场你仍然可以看到，因为 Lisa 的演讲是……我们是在周四录制的，Lisa 的演讲是在周五，Barry 的是在昨天。可能还有更多我也想看
but that's the ones that were in my head that uh you know if i went and looked at the schedule i'd probably tell you oh my god i wanted to be at a talk right now but i really enjoyed um gabor horvath's talk from this morning about. It was about sort of compiler algorithms. Yeah, I saw that too. I didn't see the talk. I saw a good one. Yeah, I wanted, that was, I saw that too late. I was looking this morning at the schedule,
但那些是我脑海中的，你知道，如果我去查看时间表，我可能会告诉你，天哪，我现在想去听一场演讲，但我真的很喜欢 Gabor Horvath 今天早上关于……的演讲。它是关于某种编译器算法的。是的，我也看到了。我没看那场演讲。我看到了一个好的。是的，我想……那是……我看到得太晚了。我今天早上在看时间表，
and I'm like, oh, I missed something that I was kind of, it looked interesting, yeah. It wasn't so much about sort of classical algorithms as we might know them, but he presented in particular a sort of algebra of recurrence chains, which the compiler uses to analyze loops and turn them into closed form expressions. Yeah. There's got to be a lot of magic going on in compilers, right?
我就想，哦，我错过了一些我有点……它看起来很有趣，是的。它与其说是关于我们可能知道的经典算法，不如说是他展示了一种特殊的递归链代数，编译器用它来分析循环并将它们转化为闭式表达式。是的。编译器里一定有很多魔法在发生，对吧？
So there's been so many years of research into that kind of stuff. Yeah. So that was a good talk. There have also been a couple of good talks from Peter Somerlad and I just saw Anthony Williams. They were talking about similar, you know... Strong types. Strong types. Yeah. Strong types. Big fan. Big fan of strong types. types type types plus what did i say yesterday types plus functions equals programming that's my new thing man that's that's my book my book is called types plus functions equals programming no one's done a book with a similar name have they
所以对那种东西的研究已经有很多年了。是的。所以那是一场很好的演讲。Peter Somerlad 也有几场很好的演讲，我刚刚看到了 Anthony Williams。他们在谈论类似的，你知道……强类型。强类型。是的。强类型。大粉丝。强类型的大粉丝。类型类型类型加……我昨天说了什么？类型加函数等于编程，这是我的新东西，伙计，那是我的书，我的书叫“类型加函数等于编程”。没有人写过名字相似的书，对吧？
practically the name of this podcast which we stole from the book that uh yeah tony's joking it's it's from nicholas verth's famous book, which I have not read yet. Bryce and I said at some point we'll read it. We can't steal the name of a book and call our podcast without reading it. What is the name of it? It's algorithms plus data structures equals programs. See, I think that's almost redundant, right? Having a data structure without an algorithm tied to it isn't
实际上是这个播客的名字，我们是从那本书里偷来的，那个……是的，Tony 在开玩笑，它来自 Nicholas Wirth 的著名书，我还没读过。Bryce 和我在某个时候说我们会读它。我们不能在不读它的情况下偷一本书的名字并称我们的播客。它的名字是什么？它是“算法加数据结构等于程序”。看，我认为这几乎是多余的，对吧？拥有一个没有算法绑定的数据结构不是
like they they kind of are the same they're intertwined yeah you know what i mean um like you know i've got a heap well if i don't have the heapifying algorithms to go with it i don't really i can't do much with this right i need the i need the two pieces together whereas types plus plus functions that's open that's open-ended right, right? I've got a string type. I've got an image type. I can write Photoshop. I should have used Photoshop as an example yesterday. I want image.photoshop to be the function on my image class, right?
就像它们……它们有点相同，它们是交织在一起的。是的，你知道我的意思……就像，你知道，我有一个堆，嗯，如果我没有与之配套的堆化算法，我真的……我不能用这个做太多事情，对吧？我需要这两个部分在一起，而类型加函数，那是开放式的，对吧？我有一个字符串类型。我有一个图像类型。我可以写 Photoshop。我昨天应该用 Photoshop 作为例子。我希望 image.photoshop 成为我的图像类上的函数，对吧？
No one makes member functions. Like everyone makes everything a member function, but Photoshop is not a member function of image unless it is. Maybe I haven't looked at Photoshop source code in a long time. Maybe that's what they've got to now. It's just like, oh yeah, just make it a member function like everything else.
没有人制作成员函数。就像每个人都把一切都做成成员函数，但 Photoshop 不是图像的成员函数，除非它是。也许我很久没看 Photoshop 的源代码了。也许这就是他们现在所拥有的。它只是像，哦，是的，就像其他一切一样把它做成成员函数。
I'm pretty sure it's not, Sean. Sean would not allow that. Yeah, he would not allow that. Well, the other, the dichotomy I've been thinking about lately is computation plus IO. It's not as catchy, but like program, when you come down to it, does computation and does IO.
我很确定它不是，Sean。Sean 不会允许那样做的。是的，他不会允许那样做的。嗯，我最近一直在思考的另一个二分法是计算加 IO。它不像那样朗朗上口，但就像程序，当你归结为它时，它做计算并做 IO。
If it doesn't do one of those things, it's basically useless. Well, yesterday I was describing some threading, and I said for threads, the rule is just don't share any data. People write threads, and they put locks around their data and then they try to share their data between threads. And well, now you've slowed yourself down because they're going to wait for each other. It's like, why did you make threads
如果它不做其中一件事，它基本上是无用的。嗯，昨天我正在描述一些线程，我说对于线程，规则只是不要共享任何数据。人们编写线程，他们在数据周围放置锁，然后他们试图在线程之间共享数据。好吧，现在你减慢了自己的速度，因为它们会互相等待。就像，你为什么要制作线程
and then put them in line to wait on objects on a mutex or something? But you also get all these bugs and everything. But if you just hand off data to a thread and don't share any data after that, then you don't have any problems. Of course, if you have a thread that never shares information, it's the same problem.
然后把它们排成一行等待互斥锁上的对象或其他东西？但你也得到了所有这些错误和一切。但如果你只是把数据交给一个线程，之后不共享任何数据，那么你就没有任何问题。当然，如果你有一个从不共享信息的线程，那是同样的问题。
It doesn't do it. It's out there calculating pi and then never tells you the answer. Just like, wow, great. Thanks thread. You know? So eventually, yeah, you have to have IO. You have to communicate data back or something, or it's kind of, kind of worthless have IO. You have to communicate data back or something, or it's kind of worthless.
它不做任何事。它在那里计算圆周率，然后从不告诉你答案。就像，哇，太棒了。谢谢线程。你知道吗？所以最终，是的，你必须有 IO。你必须传回数据或其他东西，否则它有点……有点毫无价值。你必须有 IO。你必须传回数据或其他东西，否则它有点毫无价值。
Yeah, I think I saw a tweet a while back, which is like every program transforms data structures until it gets to one it can print out. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, I almost think of now that the data structures is way less than algorithms, because I'm falling in love with APL, where they don't really have data structures. All algorithms. I was going to say, there's vector.
是的，我想我前段时间看到一条推文，就像每个程序都在转换数据结构，直到它得到一个可以打印出来的。是的，差不多。是的，我几乎认为现在数据结构远少于算法，因为我爱上了 APL，他们并没有真正的数据结构。全是算法。我正要说，有向量。
And then you're done. I need to apologize, because Jason's talk. Oh, yeah. Which was another great talk, another great talk. It's a great talk. Jason, about two-thirds of the way through the talk, he talked about exactly what Conor's been talking about lately, about the sort of foundational languages or languages that embody different computational paradigms.
然后你就完成了。我需要道歉，因为 Jason 的演讲。哦，是的。那是另一场很棒的演讲，另一场很棒的演讲。这是一场很棒的演讲。Jason，在演讲进行到三分之二时，他谈到了 Conor 最近一直在谈论的内容，关于某种基础语言或体现不同计算范式的语言。
And I was in the virtual audience. He sort of pulled me into his talk to say a few words. And I totally failed to mention APL. I was watching it because I even thought about it. You thought? You didn't tell us that. But it was Jason's talk. I didn't want to interrupt and take the mic away from him.
我当时在虚拟观众中。他把我拉进了他的演讲，说了几句话。我完全没提到 APL。我当时在看它，因为我甚至想到了它。你想到过？你没告诉我们。但那是 Jason 的演讲。我不想打断并从他手中抢走麦克风。
Anyone's talk is worth being interrupted just for a short mention of APL. And the ironic thing is, I planned on watching Jason's talk live, but I forgot that I had a podcast rehearsal for a breaking news, a other podcast that I'll be on about array programming languages. I think it's going to be called Arraycast and it's going to focus on languages like APLJ, K and Q, which are lesser well-known, but are very popular in the finance industries. What letters are still available? None of them.
任何人的演讲都值得被打断，哪怕只是为了简短地提到 APL。讽刺的是，我计划现场观看 Jason 的演讲，但我忘了我有一个关于突发新闻的播客排练，另一个我将参加的关于数组编程语言的播客。我想它会被称为 Arraycast，它将专注于像 APL、J、K 和 Q 这样的语言，它们不太出名，但在金融行业非常流行。还有什么字母可用？一个都没有。
There's actually, I'll link it in the show notes. There's an article that shows every single letter in the alphabet is taken. Some of them are less popular. I think the predecessor to R, which is like a statistical language, was S. So not many people know about S, but it was. You're going to have to go to non-Latin alphabets oh yeah i want t is t t i want t t is mine i had this plan for you said you were gonna call it tea though so yeah i was i was tossing between the two which which one to call it so i wanted that pun in there something i wanted you know is it t for tony or tea for the drink you know but yeah um anyways i ended up i ended up missing it live because i was doing some other apl stuff
实际上，我会在节目说明中链接它。有一篇文章显示字母表中的每一个字母都被占用了。其中一些不太受欢迎。我想 R 的前身，也就是一种统计语言，是 S。所以没多少人知道 S，但它是。你将不得不使用非拉丁字母……哦，是的，我想要 T，T，我想要 T，T 是我的。我有一个计划，你说你要叫它 Tea。所以是的，我在两者之间徘徊，叫哪一个。所以我想要那个双关语，我想要你知道，是 Tony 的 T 还是饮料的 Tea，你知道，但无论如何，我最终错过了现场直播，因为我正在做其他 APL 的事情
and then i was watching it in the recording and then saw ben come on talking about other languages and i was oh this is great apl is going to get a shout out he mentions haskell he mentions small talk and then doesn't mention apl sorry and my heart broke this you know c++ now has always been the conference that is half audience participation like i've literally given the same talk in 45 minutes it's an hour and a half talk at c++ now and it's 45 minute talk somewhere else, right? Because I just expect it to be filled with the audience. And I mean, I was doing a keynote and I had too much, I had too many slides. I had over 300 slides for my keynote. That was kind of scary. I knew I didn't have time to just have a conversation with the audience, but there's actually, if we did it right, you know, we could have a pretty good talks
然后我在看录音，然后看到 Ben 出来谈论其他语言，我就想，哦，这太棒了，APL 会得到一个大喊大叫。他提到了 Haskell，他提到了 Smalltalk，然后没有提到 APL。抱歉，我的心碎了。你知道，C++ Now 一直是那种有一半观众参与的会议，就像我真的在 45 分钟内做了同样的演讲，在 C++ Now 是一个半小时的演讲，而在其他地方是 45 分钟的演讲，对吧？因为我只是期望它被观众填满。我的意思是，我当时在做主题演讲，我有太多，我有太多的幻灯片。我的主题演讲有超过 300 张幻灯片。那有点可怕。我知道我没有时间只是和观众进行对话，但实际上，如果我们做得对，你知道，我们可以有相当好的演讲
where it's like, just let the audience speak live over Zoom or whatever we're using, right? Just instead of like the one version of my postmodern, the first version of postmodern, because I went onto YouTube afterwards and fixed the closed captioning. And there's a point in the closed captioning where I say, you know say it just shows up in the
就像，只是让观众通过 Zoom 或我们使用的任何东西现场发言，对吧？而不是像我的后现代版本，后现代的第一个版本，因为我事后去了 YouTube 并修复了隐藏式字幕。在隐藏式字幕中有一个点，我说，你知道，它只是出现在
bottom. It says Chandler asking a question or Chandler says something. Then it says dot, dot, dot. Then Chandler's still speaking. Dot, dot, dot. It's like a minute and a half. It's really good content. It's Chandler. He's making a great point.
底部。它说 Chandler 问了一个问题，或者 Chandler 说了什么。然后它说点，点，点。然后 Chandler 还在说话。点，点，点。那是一分半钟。那是很好的内容。那是 Chandler。他提出了一个很好的观点。
It takes him over a minute to make this great point. I'm just standing on stage. If you're watching on youtube all you get is chandler still speaking because you can't quite hear what he's saying right and then of course someone's like repeat the question for a minute like yeah but you know if you had everyone had a good you know everyone's sitting at their desks or whatever have have a microphone there you can you could actually get a good conversation going and you know it might it might be advantageous if we did it right yeah i did the captioning um i think that year um the context for all the things talk when that went up on youtube i went and i curated the captioning and i actually sort of turned up the volume
他花了一分多钟才提出这个很好的观点。我只是站在舞台上。如果你在 YouTube 上观看，你得到的只是 Chandler 还在说话，因为你听不清他在说什么，对吧？然后当然有人说，重复这个问题一分钟，就像，是的，但你知道，如果每个人都有一个好的，你知道每个人都坐在他们的桌子前或什么，那里有一个麦克风，你可以实际上进行一场很好的对话，你知道，如果我们做得对，这可能是有利的。是的，我做了字幕，我想那一年，当“为所有事物使用概念”的演讲在 YouTube 上发布时，我去策划了字幕，我实际上调高了音量
listened in my headphones so i could tell who was speaking and what they were saying and i put them I actually sort of turned up the volume, listened in my headphones so I could tell who was speaking and what they were saying, and I put them in the captions for that year. I was able to get most of them. You're right, there were so many. Chandler always sits at the very back, right, though? He's always at the very back row. Back right.
戴上耳机听，所以我能分辨出是谁在说话，他们在说什么，我把它们……我实际上调高了音量，戴上耳机听，所以我能分辨出是谁在说话，他们在说什么，我把它们放进了那一年的字幕里。我能够得到大部分。你是对的，有太多了。Chandler 总是坐在最后面，对吧？他总是坐在最后一排。右后方。
I hate your constexpr talk. I have to officially hate it. It constexpr talk. I have to officially hate it. It won the best talk. My postmodern did not win best talk. Were you the runner up that year? Yeah, I think so. I see. So that's why.
我讨厌你的 constexpr 演讲。我必须正式讨厌它。它 constexpr 演讲。我必须正式讨厌它。它赢得了最佳演讲。我的后现代演讲没有赢得最佳演讲。你那一年是亚军吗？是的，我想是。我明白了。所以这就是原因。
Because I was going to say there's a don't constexpr all the things tomorrow. Yeah, I was interested in that one too. Maybe I'll watch that. Isn't it Const consolation though the awards are named after you yeah and then along comes carl over next year and sweeps the board he made up new new categories that only he could fill i didn't make anything up name starts with c see like they never had a first year speaker thing first time speaker award it's actually a really good idea it's a good award it is i didn't have a chance to win that gretzky didn't gretzky didn't win uh uh rookie of the year because they didn't you know they changed the rules on them here's
因为我正要说明天有一个“不要为所有事物使用 constexpr”。是的，我也对那个感兴趣。也许我会看那个。这不是 Const 安慰奖，奖项是以你的名字命名的。是的，然后第二年 Carl Over 来了，横扫了整个董事会，他编造了只有他能填补的新类别。我没有编造任何东西，名字以 C 开头，看，就像他们从来没有第一年演讲者奖，第一次演讲者奖，这实际上是一个非常好的主意，这是一个很好的奖项。它是，我没有机会赢得那个。Gretzky 没有赢得年度最佳新秀，因为他们没有，你知道，他们改变了规则。这是一个
an anecdotal story because i i do want to get back to the... Did we have a topic? The unique nature of C++ now, no, because I had something else to say. But when I joined the Canadian ISO national body for C++, you know, Michael Wong sent out an email, who's the chair, I believe, of the Canadian C++ national body, and said, welcome. And then I'm not sure if it was the first reply, but it was in the first couple. Tony replies, because he's also a member, and says, my arch nemesis. And here I am, never having met Tony,
轶事，因为我确实想回到……我们有一个主题吗？C++ Now 的独特性质，不，因为我有别的话要说。但当我加入加拿大 ISO 国家 C++ 机构时，你知道，Michael Wong 发了一封电子邮件，我相信他是加拿大 C++ 国家机构的主席，说，欢迎。然后我不确定这是否是第一次回复，但它在最初的几个回复中。Tony 回复了，因为他也是成员，说，我的宿敌。而我在这里，从未见过 Tony，
never having conversed with him, because I don't think i'd uh i don't yeah i don't think i'd met you yet because you didn't come to c++ now 2019 yeah and um and you're like one of my favorite speakers and i'm like what what what happened what did i have done no this was this was great for me like i saw some twitter chat and i'm like hooray now someone else has taken the mantle of being tony's nemesis but uh but yeah to come back to the uniqueness of C++ Now, it's interesting, Tony, that you said, you know, that it's a lot of conversation because I think both Ben and I, we both have talks that we only want to give
从未与他交谈过，因为我不认为我……是的，我不认为我见过你，因为你没有来 C++ Now 2019。是的，而且……你是我最喜欢的演讲者之一，我就想，发生了什么，我做了什么？不，这对我来说太棒了，就像我看到一些 Twitter 聊天，我就想，万岁，现在有人接过了成为 Tony 宿敌的衣钵。但……是的，回到 C++ Now 的独特性，很有趣，Tony，你说，你知道，它有很多对话，因为我认为 Ben 和我，我们都有我们只想做的演讲
and have not given up to this point that we initially had submitted to C++ Now 2020. And then like, I thought about giving it at CppCon, but like I, in my head, had like specifically designed this talk for like the C++ Now experience because it's just more interactive. You get more engagement. And that's, I actually, I wasn't sure what John was gonna do
并且到目前为止还没有放弃，我们最初提交给了 C++ Now 2020。然后，我想过在 CppCon 上做这个演讲，但在我的脑海里，我专门为 C++ Now 的体验设计了这个演讲，因为它更具互动性。你能获得更多的参与感。而且，我其实不太确定 John 会怎么做
cause it's obviously difficult, but I did, there was a, I thought there was a small percentage chance that it was going to happen in Zoom and everyone would have the ability, if not to just sort of interrupt, but at least like sort of in Google meetings, you can start a hand queue and then pass the mic off. Like I thought there might be something like that, but you know, probably the technical challenges of doing that without it becoming a total mess i also have a talk that's c++ now only that that i've been holding off on and it's and it's actually in my
因为这显然很困难，但我确实认为，有很小的几率它会在 Zoom 上发生，每个人都有能力，如果不是直接打断，至少像在 Google 会议中那样，你可以发起一个排队举手，然后把麦克风传下去。我以为可能会有类似的东西，但你知道，在不造成彻底混乱的情况下做到这一点可能存在技术挑战。我还有一个只针对 C++ Now 的演讲，我一直搁置着，它实际上在我的
head which so it may never happen now but it's it's a keynote for c++ now that uh that's been in my mind for years and years but uh because it's a unique conference and so i'm like this this would not make sense anywhere else it goes back to the basis of mathematics with gotlip frega and birchen russell and all this kind of stuff it's like i don't know where else to give that talk so maybe someday maybe it won't be a keynote maybe it'll just be a i'll just give it as a talk that's what i should do i should just propose it next year or the year after or whatever. Well, the benefit is that you get to sweep all the awards then. If you demote your keynote talk to a regular talk,
脑子里，所以现在可能永远不会发生了，但它是 C++ Now 的一个主题演讲，多年来一直在我脑海中，但因为这是一个独特的会议，所以我认为它在其他任何地方都没有意义。它回到了数学的基础，比如戈特洛布·弗雷格（Gotlob Frege）和伯特兰·罗素（Bertrand Russell）等等。我不知道还能在哪里做这个演讲，所以也许有一天，也许它不会是主题演讲，也许我只是把它作为一个普通演讲，这就是我应该做的。我应该在明年或后年或者什么时候提议它。嗯，好处是你到时候可以横扫所有奖项。如果你把你的主题演讲降级为普通演讲，
you're basically a shooter to win everything. No, I took my best shot. It's never going to happen now. Well, I'm expecting the first year back to in-person C++ now is going to be a hallmark year with everyone giving these saved-up talks, apparently. Yeah.
你基本上就是赢定了一切。不，我尽力了。现在永远不会发生了。嗯，我预计 C++ Now 回归线下的第一年将是一个标志性的一年，显然每个人都会发表这些积攒已久的演讲。是的。
The other thing, too, is the virtual conference has 30-minute breaks. For me, the best part, which is they call it the hallway track, but it's the schedule. Everyone's like the schedule like everyone's on the same time zone whereas right now we're not like i think tony and i are both in the same time zone but ben is two hours behind and there's folks in europe that you know signed
另一件事是，虚拟会议有 30 分钟的休息时间。对我来说，最好的部分，也就是他们所说的走廊轨道，但它是日程安排。每个人都像日程安排一样，每个人都在同一个时区，而现在我们不是，我想托尼和我都在同一个时区，但本晚了两个小时，而且有欧洲的人，你知道，注册了
up that only watch like the last talk of the day so it's that's completely different which is it's a it's uh it's got a silver lining in that people from all over the world can attend that might not have been able to travel. But one of the really nice things about C++ now is that they've got such long breaks in between talks. Not all of them are long. Some of them are only 30 minutes, but they have like an extra long lunch break. They usually have like a long break in between the keynotes in the evening. And I can't remember if it was someone in the three of us or someone
却只看了当天最后一场演讲，所以这完全不同，它有一个好处，就是世界各地无法旅行的人都可以参加。但 C++ Now 真正好的地方之一是演讲之间有很长的休息时间。并不是所有的都很长。有些只有 30 分钟，但他们有超长的午休时间。他们通常在晚上的主题演讲之间有很长的休息时间。我不记得是我们三个人中的某个人还是某个人
else that said that like the fact that at an in-person conference you go and see a talk and then everyone upon exiting the room is standing next to each other and it's just everyone just starts chatting about it whereas here you know it's only a percentage of if we do ever do this again or you know the CP con coming up or whatever it we need to make sure when people leave the talk you just automatically end up in the same spot right everyone's kind of nearby or it's or it's really quick to get to because what happens in a normal you know in a live talk or in-person talk, people walk up to the stage,
说了，在现场会议上，你去看一场演讲，然后每个人离开房间时都站在一起，大家就开始聊天，而在这里，你知道，只有一部分人。如果我们再这样做，或者你知道即将到来的 CppCon 之类的，我们需要确保当人们离开演讲时，你们会自动出现在同一个地方，对吧？每个人都在附近，或者很容易到达，因为在正常的现场演讲中，人们会走到舞台前，
the people who, for whatever reason, don't want to ask a question to everybody, but they still want to ask the question to the speaker. And so they go up to the stage after, and that's great. I'm quite happy to answer those questions after the talk, right? And you end up, yeah, you end up with good conversations. And I mean, at C++ Now, you end up going to lunch. That's like- Right, and then writing a paper. Yeah. Whatever.
那些因为某种原因不想问大家问题，但仍然想问演讲者问题的人。所以他们会在演讲后走到舞台前，这很好。我很乐意在演讲后回答这些问题，对吧？你会得到很好的对话。我的意思是，在 C++ Now，你最终会去吃午饭。就像——对，然后写一篇论文。是的。随便吧。
If you ever wanna get hooked into doing some work for the committee, all you gotta do is ask a question after a committee member gives a talk and then you'll be writing a paper for them. Who doesn't want that? But then you get to say, I went out to lunch with, you know, somebody, somebody want to go to lunch with the Tony of the Tony Awards
如果你想参与为委员会做些工作，你所要做的就是在委员会成员演讲后问一个问题，然后你就会为他们写论文。谁不想这样呢？但你可以说，我和某某人出去吃午饭了，有人想和 C++ Now 的托尼奖得主一起吃午饭吗？
of C++ now I think that's how I think I first met Bjorn Bjorn a big on to lunch right at a you know he came and spoke at Adobe one time it's like then we all had food and I'm like I could just go and sit next to this guy. Yeah. Well, that's how that's how it is. It's a C++ now. Right. You know, I I come in never. You know, I roll into the conference, never really been part of the community before. And I'm having a problem with some C++. So I go and ask Chandler how this is supposed to get optimized. And he tells me. Right. Yeah.
我想我就是那样第一次见到比雅尼（Bjarne）的，去吃午饭，对吧？他有一次来 Adobe 演讲，然后我们都吃了饭，我想我可以去坐在那个人旁边。是的。嗯，C++ Now 就是这样。对。你知道，我从来没有参加过。你知道，我来到会议，以前从未真正成为社区的一部分。我遇到了一些 C++ 问题。所以我去问钱德勒（Chandler）这应该如何优化。他告诉了我。对。是的。
That's literally the exact interactions like that happen all the time yeah it's literally the exact same mine was several years after you ben but i showed up absolutely know it like i'd never been to a conference in my life let alone spoken at one or vice versa switch those two around and then the slide in my algorithm intuition talk with adjacent difference calculating fibonacci like that came from a conversation with ben where i was saying oh you know you can do from a conversation with Ben, where I was saying, oh, you know, you can do Fibonacci with transform. And then Ben was like, hold my beer, you know, you can do Fibonacci with adjacent difference. And I was like, no, you can't. And he's like, yeah. And then I thought about it for a second. And I was just like, oh, my God, that's one of the worst named algorithms ever. Like, how are you going to
那确实是那种互动，一直都在发生。是的，这确实是一模一样的。我的比你晚几年，本，但我出现时绝对什么都不知道，我这辈子从来没参加过会议，更不用说在会议上发言了，或者反过来。把这两个换一下，然后在我的算法直觉演讲中，用 adjacent_difference 计算斐波那契数列，那来自我和本的对话，当时我说，哦，你知道你可以用 transform 做斐波那契。然后本说，看着我的啤酒，你知道，你可以用 adjacent_difference 做斐波那契。我说，不，你不能。他说，是的。然后我想了一会儿。我就想，哦，天哪，那是命名最糟糕的算法之一。就像，你怎么会
recognize that that's, it's just adjacent elements, You can do anything you want. You don't have to subtract. And yeah, that experience is, it's like, I don't want to say it's a C++ now only thing, but it just, it's those kinds of conversations seems to happen a lot more for whatever reason. Speaking of, you know, coming up with pieces of your talk while you're talking to people uh i i'm making the i'm making my lightning talk right now so you want to give us a sneak peek no i don't want to give you i want you to give me i need stuff for my stuff all right so so so like i mentioned i barely mentioned it yesterday and and phil i got it from Phil, right? Phil did a talk on Solid. In his talk, he references Rich Hickey, right, who did Closure.
认出那是，它只是相邻元素，你可以做任何你想做的事。你不必做减法。是的，那种体验，我不想说它是 C++ Now 特有的，但无论出于什么原因，这类对话似乎发生得更多。说到在和人交谈时想出演讲片段，我正在制作我的闪电演讲，所以你想给我们先睹为快吗？不，我不想给你，我需要你给我，我需要我的东西的材料。好吧，就像我提到的，我昨天刚提到它，菲尔（Phil），我是从菲尔那里得到的，对吧？菲尔做了一个关于 Solid 的演讲。在他的演讲中，他引用了 Rich Hickey，对吧，他做了 Clojure。
And Rich Hickey does a talk called Simple Made Easy, right? And he goes into the Latin, simple and complex. They come from Latin, plecto and plictere and all this stuff. And it's all about fold. And, you know, simple as one fold and complex as many folds interleaving. And he uses this old word called complex and complexing to mean entangling and interleaving. Right. And that's what happens in our software all the time. Things get entangled. Like, you know, it's kind of half of my talk yesterday. Right.
Rich Hickey 做了一个叫“简单即容易”（Simple Made Easy）的演讲，对吧？他深入研究了拉丁语，simple 和 complex。它们来自拉丁语 plecto 和 plictere 等等。这都是关于折叠的。你知道，simple 是一次折叠，complex 是多次折叠交织在一起。他使用了一个古老的词叫 complex 和 complexing，意思是纠缠和交织。对。这就是我们的软件中一直发生的事情。事情变得纠缠不清。就像，你知道，这大概是我昨天演讲的一半。对。
So it's kind of like while I was giving my talk yesterday and after my talk as real I realize it's like I want my lightning talk to be complecting made easy right because because it's exactly what happens like why is our software you know turn into crap is because we make it too easy to let it turn into crap right it's it's the the easy answer to solve a problem is like the one that entangles your code right so you know having a lot of uh data close by is basically and so and the other half is that easy the the the term easy um also comes from you, you can trace it back to Latin.
所以就像我昨天演讲时和演讲后，我意识到我想让我的闪电演讲成为“复杂化即容易”（Complecting Made Easy），因为这正是发生的事情。为什么我们的软件变成了垃圾，是因为我们让它太容易变成垃圾了，对吧？解决问题的简单答案就是那种让你的代码纠缠在一起的答案，对吧？所以，你知道，拥有大量靠近的数据基本上就是这样。另一半是 easy 这个词，你也可以追溯到拉丁语。
It's kind of fuzzy. They're not really sure, but it comes from adjacent, which is, you know, like adjacent. It really means close at hand. Easy means close at hand, right? So, complecting made easy is what our code does. We put things close at hand, and we're just like, hey, did you want to solve this problem? All you got to do is, is this thing's right here. You could just braid them together. It's just, if we're just tempting you, we put all this stuff in the right spot. Why don't you just braid it together? So, I mean, one thing I, like global variables, I should, I have to write this down because I keep forgetting it. Maybe I won't make my slides, but I'll write, I'll write it down
它有点模糊。他们不太确定，但它来自 adjacent，也就是，你知道，像相邻。它真正的意思是近在咫尺。Easy 的意思是近在咫尺，对吧？所以，复杂化即容易就是我们的代码所做的。我们把东西放在近在咫尺的地方，我们就像，嘿，你想解决这个问题吗？你所要做的就是，这些东西就在这里。你可以把它们编织在一起。这只是，如果我们只是在诱惑你，我们把所有这些东西都放在正确的位置。你为什么不把它们编织在一起呢？所以，我的意思是，有一件事，比如全局变量，我应该，我必须把它写下来，因为我一直忘记它。也许我不会做幻灯片，但我会写下来
while we're talking. Global variables, right? Global variables. It's right there. I could just read this global variable and, you know, complex my code. And then the next best thing to a global variable is? Shared pointer. Shared pointer. Thank you very much.
在我们交谈的时候。全局变量，对吧？全局变量。它就在那里。我可以读取这个全局变量，然后，你知道，让我的代码复杂化。那么仅次于全局变量的东西是什么？共享指针（Shared pointer）。共享指针。非常感谢。
Yeah, shared pointer. What we have in our code is a class called model that I always bring up right everyone has a pointer back to model it'd be okay to have a model that owns everything because you always are stuck with a class that has to own everything otherwise things just disappear right right but everything has a pointer back to model so I have places in my code where there's literally five layers deep of, I've got model as a member variable and just a raw pointer, right? Pointing back to my parent, right?
是的，共享指针。我们的代码中有一个叫 model 的类，我总是提到它，每个人都有一个指向 model 的指针。拥有一个拥有所有东西的 model 是可以的，因为你总是被一个必须拥有所有东西的类所困，否则东西就会消失，对吧？对，但每样东西都有一个指向 model 的指针。所以我的代码中有一些地方确实有五层深，我有 model 作为成员变量，只是一个原始指针，对吧？指向我的父级，对吧？
Model pointing to foo, pointing to bar, pointing to thing, pointing. Ah, that's what I needed. I needed this piece of information and I can get at it through this five step path. Model is the convenience store. Yeah. Yeah. It's all there. You just go to model.
Model 指向 foo，指向 bar，指向 thing，指向。啊，这就是我需要的。我需要这条信息，我可以通过这个五步路径得到它。Model 是便利店。是的。是的。它都在那里。你只要去 model 就行了。
So having exposure to model is complecting made easy. It's like, it's all there you just go to model so yeah having exposure to model is complecting made easy it's like it's right here you don't have to make up an interface you don't have to put in the right function for how you know i should have this information should have been passed down to me through three layers of function calls that that's that's hard that's correct code made hard right like uh simple simple is not folding your code together. So simple is hard to do. And complecting is easy to do because we expose model. You know, that's the problem in our class.
所以接触 model 就是复杂化即容易。就像，它都在那里，你只要去 model 就行了，所以是的，接触 model 就是复杂化即容易。就像，它就在这里，你不必编造一个接口，你不必放入正确的函数，关于你知道，我应该把这些信息通过三层函数调用传递给我，那才是难的，那才是正确的代码变难了，对吧？就像，简单不是把你的代码折叠在一起。所以简单是很难做到的。而复杂化是容易做到的，因为我们暴露了 model。你知道，这就是我们类中的问题。
So I've got three examples. I need more. How is complecting made easy? I think there's a time element, I was going to say, because Rich Hickey in his talk talks about easy is a function of mental ease as well, right, which is a function of time, right? What's close in time, what you immediately think of is the easy. When you're given time to reflect and work on a problem, then you perhaps come up with something that's simpler. Yeah, and I also find people, you work from an area that you already know, right?
所以我有了三个例子。我需要更多。复杂化是如何变得容易的？我想有一个时间因素，我本来想说，因为 Rich Hickey 在他的演讲中谈到 easy 也是心理上的轻松的一个函数，对吧，这是时间的一个函数，对吧？什么在时间上是接近的，你立刻想到的就是容易。当你被给予时间去反思和处理一个问题时，你也许会想出更简单的东西。是的，我也发现人们，你从你已经知道的领域工作，对吧？
It's like, well, I know this part of the code, and I've touched this class before, so I'll just go from here, right? I've got, this is the information I know, and then I will just, it's like, well, you know, if you just went over there and asked that other class to give you the thing you want to know, that would work. And you're like, yeah, but I've never touched that class before. I don't, I don't want to touch that code. It's easy to write code. It's easy to just type. It's harder to grep and find the interface that already exists, maybe. Yeah.
就像，嗯，我知道代码的这一部分，我以前接触过这个类，所以我从这里开始，对吧？我有，这是我知道的信息，然后我就会，就像，嗯，你知道，如果你去那边问那个类给你你想要知道的东西，那也会奏效。你会说，是的，但我以前从没接触过那个类。我不想碰那段代码。写代码很容易。打字很容易。grep 并找到已经存在的接口可能更难。是的。
This isn't really an example, but twice now, this has come up, like it's popped into my head while you've been talking, Tony, is I'm not sure if Yarnastrewship was the first person to hear this or to say this, but it's where I heard it first, is that so many people mistakes familiarity for simplicity. Yeah. And that because it's what you're used to working with, it seems simple. And then some new thing that potentially is unfamiliar looks complicated. But if you take the time to restructure at the end of the day, it actually is, it is objectively simpler than what you had before. But what you know, like sort of affects what you think is simple. Yeah, that is, and that is what Rich Hickey's talk also mentions, right? That is, it's almost literally close at hand. It's close in your knowledge base, right? It's like, think is simple yeah that that is and that is what the rich hickeys talk also mentions right that is it's almost literally close at hand it's close in your knowledge base right it's like i already know this and this is just one step away from what i already know it's familiar right it's like oh i
这算不上一个例子，但已经两次了，这出现了，就像它在我脑海中跳出来，当你说话的时候，托尼，我不确定 Bjarne Stroustrup 是否是第一个听到或说出这句话的人，但这是我第一次听到的，就是很多人把熟悉误认为是简单。是的。因为那是你习惯使用的东西，所以它看起来很简单。然后一些潜在的不熟悉的新事物看起来很复杂。但如果你花时间在最后重构，它实际上在客观上比你以前拥有的更简单。但你所知道的，会影响你认为什么是简单的。是的，Rich Hickey 的演讲也提到了这一点，对吧？那就是，它几乎字面上就是近在咫尺。它在你的知识库中很接近，对吧？就像，认为简单，是的，那确实是 Rich Hickey 的演讲也提到的，对吧？那就是，它几乎字面上就是近在咫尺。它在你的知识库中很接近，对吧？就像我本来就知道这个，这离我本来就知道的东西只有一步之遥，它很熟悉，对吧？就像，哦，我
already know whatever this language or you know you you solve a problem like we get that when we're interviewing people right interviewing i showing, I show someone this problem. Hey, can you solve this problem? And you'll see someone solving it with like, I'm just like, why would you think of this as their, you know, I'm going to solve it with probability. Something, something and fine. And I just listen to it. It's like, oh, because the last problem they solve, they solve that way. Right.
本来就知道这个语言，或者你知道，你解决一个问题，就像我们在面试人时得到的那样，对吧？面试，我给某人看这个问题。嘿，你能解决这个问题吗？你会看到有人用，我只是想，你为什么会认为这是他们的，你知道，我要用概率来解决它。什么什么，然后很好。我只是听着。就像，哦，因为他们解决的上一个问题，他们就是那样解决的。对。
It's just like I'm familiar with solving problems with this technique. So I'm going to try to apply my technique to this problem. And I'm like, okay, let's try something else. Cause it's, this is just not, you know, you don't want to just tell somebody you're totally going down the wrong path, but I give them time. And then I go like, that might work, but what else? Give me some more ideas on how that might work. You know, give me some other way to solve this problem. But really what I'm saying, I'll let you know if anyone interviews with me, if I start asking you for other ideas and I don't say your first idea is wrong, I'm really saying your first idea is terrible. Just in a nice way. It's like, oh, that is pretty interesting. But what other ways do you think you could do this? This is cause now a great future moment, the moment that is yet to happen of when this happens, when you're interviewing someone
就像我熟悉用这种技术解决问题。所以我打算尝试把我的技术应用到这个问题上。我就说，好吧，让我们试试别的。因为它，这只是不，你知道，你不想直接告诉某人你完全走错了路，但我给他们时间。然后我说，那可能行得通，但还有别的吗？给我更多关于它如何工作的想法。你知道，给我一些其他方法来解决这个问题。但实际上我是在说，如果有人面试我，我会让你知道，如果我开始向你要其他想法，而我不说你的第一个想法是错的，我其实是在说你的第一个想法很糟糕。只是用一种委婉的方式。就像，哦，那很有趣。但你认为你还能用什么其他方式来做这件事？这是因为现在一个伟大的未来时刻，那个尚未发生的时刻，当这种情况发生时，当你面试某人
that just happens to have listened to this episode, you say that and they're going to be like, oh no, it's terrible. I listened to that episode, Tony. And you're going to be like, oh, well. We may not be, your friend Ahmad, right?
恰好听过这一集，你说那句话，他们会说，哦不，太糟糕了。我听过那一集，托尼。你会说，哦，好吧。我们可能不是，你的朋友艾哈迈德（Ahmad），对吧？
Yeah. We were just talking to yesterday. I've been talking to him about like working here as a co-op. Right? So we could be this far away from it happening. Cool. I'll change my phrasing. I'll just try something else.
是的。我们昨天刚谈过。我一直在和他谈论在这里做实习生。对吧？所以我们离它发生可能只有这么远。酷。我会改变我的措辞。我会尝试别的方法。
So I gave a talk at the Denver meetup a few months ago now. And it was one of those talks that was, I needed to give it at the meetup because it wasn't a lightning talk and it wasn't a full talk. It was in that 20, 25 minute range, which is so annoying. But the talk was called the blacksmith and the gardener, meaning the two sides of what we do.
所以我几个月前在丹佛聚会上做了一个演讲。那是其中一个演讲，我需要在聚会上做，因为它不是闪电演讲，也不是完整演讲。它在 20 到 25 分钟的范围内，这太烦人了。但这个演讲叫“铁匠与园丁”，意味着我们所做的两面。
Sometimes you're a blacksmith, sometimes you're forging things, you're bending the code to your will, you're a blacksmith. Sometimes you're forging things. You're bending the code to your will. You're typing, typing, typing. But that needs to be balanced with the gardener, which is you're just letting things bloom, right? You're letting yourself reflect. Because so often I found myself having the experience,
有时你是铁匠，有时你在锻造东西，你按照你的意愿弯曲代码，你是铁匠。有时你在锻造东西。你按照你的意愿弯曲代码。你在打字，打字，打字。但这需要与园丁平衡，也就是你只是让事情绽放，对吧？你让自己反思。因为我经常发现自己有这种经历，
as we all have. The cliche is you solve the problem in the shower or on the run or whatever, in times when your mind is quiet. And the experience you have, if you're lucky, is that you get a task to do, you solve it, done, you manage to knock it out, done. And if you're lucky, like a week later, you realize there's a simpler way to do it. Oftentimes, you're not that lucky, right? And so the thing stays in the code, complexified. I just do it right the first time.
正如我们所有人都有过的那样。陈词滥调是你会在洗澡或跑步时解决问题，或者无论什么，在你的头脑安静的时候。如果你幸运的话，你得到的经历是，你得到一个任务去做，你解决了它，完成了，你设法把它搞定了，完成了。如果你幸运的话，一周后你意识到有一种更简单的方法可以做到。通常，你没那么幸运，对吧？所以东西留在了代码里，复杂化了。我只是第一次就做对了。
Why doesn't everyone just do it? I never understood this, why people are always like, you know, throw the first one away. I'm like, no, the first one was good. That was one of the best parts of your talk when you just said you were like, yeah, I don't want to come across as overconfident, but most of the time I just get things right. That's, it just happens to me all the time. I had this student working for me years ago and she was great. One of her best features was that, you know, we'd be talking about some stuff and she'd go off to do some work. And she'd come back in about, you know, the end of the week or something.
为什么不是每个人都这样做？我从来没理解这一点，为什么人们总是像，你知道，把第一个扔掉。我说，不，第一个很好。那是你演讲中最好的部分之一，当你只是说，你就像，是的，我不想显得过于自信，但大多数时候我只是把事情做对了。那是，它一直发生在我身上。我多年前有一个学生为我工作，她很棒。她最好的特点之一是，你知道，我们会谈论一些事情，她会去做一些工作。她会在大约，你知道，周末结束时回来。
And she'd be like, okay, I was doing this stuff like we said, and I ran into this little problem. And I went this way, you know. She describes the problem to me. And she's like, it wasn't a big deal. But I wasn't sure, but I went this way. And I'm like, yeah, that was a good decision, right? And then she goes on. I also did this thing. and we hadn't talked about it, but I thought this made sense. I'm like, yeah, makes completely sense. And then she goes, and now I'm here,
她会说，好吧，我按照我们说的做了这些事情，我遇到了这个小问题。我走了这条路，你知道。她向我描述了这个问题。她说，这不是什么大不了的事。但我不太确定，但我走了这条路。我说，是的，那是个好决定，对吧？然后她继续。我还做了这件事。我们之前没谈过，但我认为这有道理。我说，是的，完全有道理。然后她说，现在我在这里，
and I'm not sure which way to go. And she was really good at knowing this was a big decision, and she should stop, right? And just like, she had her opinion, but she knew that she should ask somebody, because it was, you know, she recognized it was a big decision. I thought that was great. Like that's a good insight into the whole world of programming. And so she discussed the problem and she'd be like, you know, I could go this way. I could go left or I could go right. You know, blah, blah, blah, different ways of doing it.
我不确定该走哪条路。她非常擅长知道这是一个重大决定，她应该停下来，对吧？就像，她有她的意见，但她知道她应该问某人，因为，你知道，她意识到这是一个重大决定。我觉得那太棒了。就像那是对整个编程世界的深刻见解。所以她讨论了这个问题，她会说，你知道，我可以走这条路。我可以向左走，也可以向右走。你知道，等等，不同的做法。
And I'm like, yeah, yeah. And I find that i can always understand yeah that i see how that makes sense i see how this one makes sense you can give me five different things i can see all five point of views you know it's really bad for being political or something like oh yeah that makes sense you know like no tony that one doesn't make sense that'd be bad those people are, yeah, but it sounded like, you know, but, um, but she would go through the things and she was like, which way should we go? And I have this gut instinct of which way we should go. And I'm like, well, this one makes sense to me, but I can't say why I think
我说，是的，是的。我发现我总是能理解，是的，我明白为什么那有道理，我明白为什么这个有道理，你可以给我五个不同的东西，我能看到所有五个观点，你知道，这对从政什么的真的很糟糕，就像，哦，是的，那有道理，你知道，就像，不，托尼，那个没道理，那会很糟糕，那些人是，是的，但听起来，你知道，但是，嗯，但她会经历这些事情，她就像，我们应该走哪条路？我有这种直觉，我们应该走哪条路。我说，嗯，这条对我来说有道理，但我不能说为什么我认为
it's better than any other way. So I usually would just say, whichever one you're most comfortable with, because you're going to be the one writing the code. And unless I see like why it's obviously wrong or something, it's fine. They're all they're all roughly equivalent. Go in whatever direction you're comfortable with. And then she would go off into another direction and stuff like that. And then like three months later, be like, oh, we both see it like that was not the right direction. This is we should not have gone down this way. It's like, let's do it this other way that I think just feels right to me. And it wouldn't, we'd never come back to that. It would always be like, yeah, that one worked out. And eventually after she was
它比任何其他方式都好。所以我通常只会说，无论你觉得哪一个最舒服，因为你将是写代码的人。除非我看到为什么它显然是错的之类的，否则没关系。它们都大致相当。走任何你觉得舒服的方向。然后她会走向另一个方向之类的。然后三个月后，就像，哦，我们都看到了，那不是正确的方向。这是，我们不应该走这条路。就像，让我们用我认为对我来说感觉正确的另一种方式来做。我们永远不会回到那个。它总是像，是的，那个成功了。最终在她之后
there for a couple of terms and stuff, eventually she's just like, I'm just going to do it your way. Okay. Whichever way you don't have to explain to me why you think it's the right way. We're just going to go with yours. And I'm like, all right. Let's just call it experience or something. It's just, let's go with my way from now on. It was good. We both agreed that, you know. That you're always right. And it worked out.
在那里待了几个学期之类的，最终她只是说，我只是要用你的方式做。好吧。无论哪种方式，你不必向我解释为什么你认为它是正确的方式。我们只是要用你的。我说，好吧。让我们称之为经验之类的。只是，从现在开始用我的方式吧。那很好。我们都同意，你知道。你总是对的。它成功了。
It was true. The stuff we did, it was right, and we went on with our day. I don't know. Yeah. No, that's a good... That sort of rings true. You know, I was thinking the other day, the answer with C++ is always it depends, right? Right, once you get past a certain level. And so it becomes harder and harder to give a definitive answer
这是真的。我们做的事情，它是对的，我们继续我们的一天。我不知道。是的。不，那是一个很好的……那听起来确实是真的。你知道，前几天我在想，C++ 的答案总是“视情况而定”，对吧？对，一旦你过了某个水平。所以给出明确的答案变得越来越难
when someone comes up to you and says, you know, they're looking for your opinion, they're looking for, what's the right, well, they're not even looking for your opinion, they're looking for you to give the authority.'s the right way to do this yeah how am i supposed to do this just tell me and that's a really difficult question to answer because it's always it depends and so you know maybe the way to go is well you know here's here's the experienced way it's not necessarily the the authoritatively right way i'm saying but but here's how i would do it and i and i think think is, because I've spent a lot of
当有人走到你面前说，你知道，他们在寻求你的意见，他们在寻求，什么是正确的，嗯，他们甚至不是在寻求你的意见，他们是在寻求你给出权威。这是做这件事的正确方式，是的，我该怎么做？只要告诉我。这是一个非常难回答的问题，因为它总是“视情况而定”，所以你知道，也许前进的方式是，嗯，你知道，这是经验丰富的方式，我不一定是说权威上正确的方式，但我会这样做，而且我认为，是因为我花了很多
time trying to figure out, because the sad part is I literally could not tell you why I think one way is better than the other. I just think it is, right? It just feels like the right way. And it wouldn't be till later on down the road where we're like, oh yeah, this is why that was bad and this is good. But I know after I've spent time trying to figure out what is it, and it really is keep your stuff separate. It's just like my instinct is to separate things. And I find that that instinct does not, does not fail. Right. I did it in, I did it in math. I did it like, you know, it's, it's a mathematical thing in my head. It's, it's abstraction and stuff. It's like, you know, these concepts are separate. Keep things separate. And then even if something isn't wrong, it's okay because it's all separate and you fix the one piece, right?
时间试图弄清楚，因为可悲的部分是我真的无法告诉你为什么我认为一种方式比另一种更好。我只是认为它是，对吧？它只是感觉像是正确的方式。直到后来，我们才会说，哦，是的，这就是为什么那个很糟糕，这个很好。但我知道在我花时间试图弄清楚它是什么之后，它确实是保持你的东西分开。就像我的直觉是把事情分开。我发现这种直觉不会失败。对。我在数学中做过，我做过，你知道，它在我脑海里是一个数学的东西。它是抽象之类的。就像，你知道，这些概念是分开的。保持事情分开。然后即使某件事不是错的，也没关系，因为它都是分开的，你修复那一部分，对吧？
It's like the whole thing's not wrong. Right, right. I don't know. Yeah, Ben, when you were saying that when people ask, you know, how do you do this, that reminded me in my very first job when i had become experienced sometimes folks would we would have some small job that needed to be done and be like oh well can you just give me the first couple of steps and inevitably like if i were actually doing it there's like a series of like six disjoint things that i would try like and they're all ranked and i would try the first one realize oh no that's not going to work, then try the second one, that's not going to work, and then on the fourth one of six, okay, no, this is the right way to do it, but when someone asks you, like, oh, how to do this, you,
就像整个事情不是错的。对，对。我不知道。是的，本，当你那样说时，当人们问，你知道，你怎么做这个，这让我想起我第一份工作时，当我变得有经验时，有时人们会，我们会做一些需要完成的小工作，就像，哦，好吧，你能给我前几个步骤吗？不可避免地，如果我真的在做它，就像有一系列六个不相干的事情我会尝试，它们都有排名，我会尝试第一个，意识到，哦不，那行不通，然后尝试第二个，那行不通，然后在六个中的第四个，好吧，不，这是正确的做法，但当有人问你，就像，哦，怎么做这个，你，
I typically just tell them the first thing, and I'm just like, oh, I would go down this route, and then, you know, 60 minutes later, they come back and say, well, I tried that, and it's really not working, and then I go and sit down next to them and, oh, yeah, yeah, that's clearly not going to work. So why don't you just give them the fourth one first, man? Because I don't even know that the fourth one is the right one. And that's why I think, honestly, like pair programming, I absolutely love pair programming, especially when there's a person at work,
我通常只是告诉他们第一件事，我就像，哦，我会走这条路，然后，你知道，60 分钟后，他们回来并说，嗯，我试过了，它真的行不通，然后我就去坐在他们旁边，哦，是的，是的，那显然行不通。那你为什么不先给他们第四个呢，伙计？因为我甚至不知道第四个是正确的。这就是为什么我认为，老实说，比如结对编程，我绝对喜欢结对编程，特别是有个同事，
his name's Ashwin that I work with at NVIDIA, and he's like a Python expert. And I'm a quote unquote C++ expert. And because of our library that we work on, it's Python bindings. Yes, expert with the quotations. It's the only way to do it. You can be an expert in other languages. In C++, you have to put the quotes on it. This is a tangent, but I have recently, inside my head, I used to put the Scott Schur quote at the beginning of my talks, whereas I'm not an expert. I'm just a dude. I have a new quote that I don't even know who said.
他叫 Ashwin，我和他在 NVIDIA 一起工作，他是 Python 专家。我是所谓的 C++ 专家。因为我们工作的库，它是 Python 绑定。是的，带引号的专家。这是唯一的方法。你可以成为其他语言的专家。在 C++ 中，你必须加上引号。这是一个题外话，但我最近，在我的脑海里，我过去在我的演讲开头引用 Scott Meyers 的话，但我不是专家。我只是个普通人。我有一个新的引言，我甚至不知道是谁说的。
I just heard it. And I was like, that is perfect. And it's the more I learn, the less I know. And it's this idea that, like, I like learning a bunch about different languages and paradigms. And, like, so I'm learning this stuff at a very surface level. And just all I'm doing really is discovering that there's so much more that like, I don't know. And so as I learn more, I feel less and less of an expert and more and more of like an imposter. This though is the hallmark of expertise, right?
我只是听到了。我就想，那太完美了。那就是，我学得越多，我知道的就越少。这就是这种想法，就像，我喜欢学习关于不同语言和范式的很多东西。而且，所以我正在非常浅的层面上学习这些东西。我真正做的只是发现还有更多我不知道的东西。所以随着我学得越多，我感觉自己越不像专家，越像个冒名顶替者。但这正是专业知识的标志，对吧？
The way I've heard it said is the larger your island of knowledge, the longer your coastline of ignorance. That's wow. Where'd you hear that from? We of ignorance. Hmm. That's wow. Where'd you hear that from? We got to. Somewhere. We got to Google it. Yeah, I'll try and find that's almost more eloquent than when,
我听到的说法是，你的知识岛屿越大，你的无知海岸线就越长。那太棒了。你从哪听到的？无知。嗯。那太棒了。你从哪听到的？我们得。某处。我们得去 Google 一下。是的，我会试着找到，那几乎比我，当我所说的时候更雄辩，而且什么，所以我所说的是专家，对吧。因为我们在谈论结对，这太棒了，因为我们都承认，就像。我们有我们知道的领域，而且有太多的教学，以及你是驱动者，专家就像是另一个人
than what I, when I had said and what, so what I was saying expert, right. Cause we were talking about pairing and it's just fantastic because we both sort of acknowledge like that. We have our areas of what we know and there's just so much teaching and and where you're the driver and the expert sort of is the other
指导你的人，这太棒了，因为有很多时候，不可避免地，你知道，如果你是一个人，你会花一个小时或两个小时或三个小时试图弄清楚如何做这个，然后他们会很快，他们会看到你走在路上，他们会说，好吧，那是一个很好的想法，但，让我来修复它。而且，你只是学习，这就像集中的学习。而且我只是，它太棒了。我的一个朋友，一个同事，他过去，如果我们，如果他在看你写代码，他就会慢慢开始发出声音。他只会像，嗯，嗯，嗯，它只是变得更糟。你知道，如果他一直那样，他就会慢慢开始发出声音。他只会像，呃，呃，
person guiding you it's just fantastic because there's so many times where inevitably you know that if you were by yourself you're going to spend an hour or two hours or three hours trying to figure out how to do this and then they'll quickly they'll see you going down the path and they'll say, okay, that's a really good thought, but like, let me just fix that. And it's, you just learn, it's like concentrated learning. And I just, it's, it's fantastic. A friend of mine, a coworker, he used to, if we, if he was watching you code, he would just slowly start making a noise. He'd just be like, uh, uh, uh, it just kept worse. You know, if he just kept going, he would just slowly start making a noise. He'd just be like, eh, eh,
呃，它只是变得更糟。你知道，如果他一直那样，他就像，呃，你就像，哦，
eh, it just kept worse. You know, if he just kept going, he's just like, eh, you're like, oh,
我现在应该停下来。是的。如果它只是像，你少了一个分号，那只会是一个微小的声音。对。就像，啊，
I should stop now. Yeah. If it was just like, you're missing a semicolon, it would just be a tiny little noise. Right. And just like, ah,
编译器会找到它的。但是的，如果你真的开始走错路，你只是增加音量。所以你停下来。好吧。嗯，我们，我们在这里大约一个小时了。我意识到我已经让你在下一个演讲中多待了 30 分钟，我非常期待那个演讲。所以我不太确定。你是要去下一个吗？
that compiler will find it. But yeah, if you really started going down the wrong path, you just increase the volume. So you stopped. All right. Well, we're, we're at like the hour mark here. And I realize I've already kept you 30 minutes into the next talk, which I was super looking forward to. So I'm not sure. Which is the next one you're going to?
有一个叫“作为表达式的算法”，由我不知道。那听起来像你会去的东西。那听起来很棒。是的，它是，我将发错这个名字。所以我道歉。嗯，亚历山大，嗯，Bakarikov。嗯，你本可以只用亚历山大，就像，你知道，有多少，可能没有超过一个演讲是按名字的。我可以得到名字。我可能确定我还是发错了名字。嗯，但如果，如果我跳进那个，嗯，我以后得补上前 30 分钟。但有什么，我也觉得，
There's one called algorithms as expressions by I don't. That sounds like something you'd go to. That sounds great. Yeah, it's by I'm going to mispronounce this name. So I apologize. Uh, Alexander, uh, Bakarikov. Um, you could have just went with Alexander, just like, you know, how many, there's probably not more than one talk by first name. I can get the first name. I'm probably sure that I mispronounced the first name anyways. Um, but if, if I hop into that one, uh, I'll have to catch the first 30 minutes later. But is there anything, I feel like too,
我们提到了很多人的名字。所以钱德勒指的是来自 Google 的 Chandler Carruth。埃里克指的是来自 Ranges V3 的 Eric Niebler，目前在 Facebook 工作，但做了成为 C++20 Ranges 背后的开创性工作。我觉得我们还提到了其他几个人。当我重听这个时
we've mentioned a lot of folks by first name. So Chandler refers to Chandler Carruth from Google. Eric refers to Eric Niebler from Ranges V3, currently works at Facebook, but did the pioneering work behind what's become C++20 Ranges. I feel like we've mentioned a couple other people. When I'm re-listening to this
如果我没有提到姓氏，我会尝试，只是因为我记得早些时候听 CppCast 的剧集，人们会提到像 Herb，我不知道 Herb 是谁，我们只是作为 C++ 程序员，我们假设每个人都知道 Herb Sutter 是 C++ ISO 的主席，Bjarne Stroustrup。是的。我想我说了他的名字，所以就像，是的。那是 C++ 的创造者，对于任何非 C++ 程序员。我假设每个 C++ 程序员都知道，但可能有一个……你知道，这很有趣。
if if i haven't mentioned the last name i'll try and just just because i recall listening to cpp cast episodes early on and people would refer to like herb and i didn't know who herb was and we just as c++ers we we have we assume everyone knows that herb sutter is the chair of the c++ iso bernjarne Stroustrup. Yeah. I think I said his name, so it's like, yeah. That's the creator of C++ for any non-C++. I assume every C++-er knows that, but there might be a... You know, it's funny.
我讨厌在工作中做评估，对吧？就像你得到年度评估或任何那种垃圾，我只是不。如果你不评估，我很抱歉，你只是想结束并离开这里。但如果你不是全年都在评估，就像你应该知道你的经理对你的看法。以及你管理的人，他们应该知道你的感受。这不是一年一次的事情，对吧？但你填写这些表格。而且，所以我到了一个地步，我用来自合著者、同事的引言填写了表格，对吧？它就像，它看起来就像一张电影海报。就像，很棒的想法，
I hate doing reviews at work, right? It's like you get the yearly review or whatever kind of crap, which I just don't. If you're not reviewing, I'm sorry, you're trying to end and get out of here. But if you're not reviewing all throughout the year, like you should know what your manager's opinion of you is. And your people that you're managing, they should know how you feel. It's not a one time a year thing, right? But you fill out these forms. And like, so I got to the point where I filled out the forms with quotes from co-authors, from co-workers, right? It just like, it just looks like a movie poster. It's like, awesome idea,
托尼，你知道？我只是放，我写下，我记得这个，它说，很棒的想法。你知道，克里斯汀，克里斯汀说，很棒的想法，对于一些，那就像午餐计划，但你知道，他们不需要知道那个。但我包括了，我记得包括了 Bjarne 的引言。我只是有一个来自 Bjarne 的加一之类的，类似的东西。然后我意识到我的经理不知道那是谁。就像，就像我放在我的上面的一个很好的东西，就像，看，Bjarne Stroustrup 喜欢我说的一些话。然后我就想，哦，这会在我的经理那里丢失。但是的，你知道其他每个人都知道他是谁，是的，那是，那是一个很好的，我听过一个叫 Ladybug Podcast 的播客，嗯，其中一个
Tony, you know? And I just put, I put down, I remember this one, it said, awesome idea. You know, Christine, Christine said, awesome idea for some, it was like lunch plans, but you know, they don't need to know that. But I included, I remember including a quote from Bjarne. I just had like a plus one from Bjarne or whatever, something like that. And then I realized my manager doesn't know who that is. Like, like it's such a good thing that I put on my, it's like, look, Bjarne Struestrup likes something I said. And then I'm like, oh, this is going to get lost on my manager. But yeah know everyone else knows who he is yeah that's uh that's a good uh I listen to a podcast called the ladybug podcast and uh one of
他们说的最大的事情是，每当有人说了一些好话，就把它记下来，如果你在年底当你整理一些，不是所有公司，但很多公司，你必须写你自己的绩效评估并提交。如果你有，如果 50% 只是像同事 X，你知道，说了关于这个 PR 的积极事情，同事 Y 我花了一些时间教导，说这在这一周内提高了 5 倍的生产力之类的，那是最好的东西
the biggest things they say is whenever someone like says something nice just jot it down just if you at the end of your year when you're putting together like some not all companies but a lot of companies you have to write your own sort of performance review and send it in. If you have like, if 50% of it is just like coworker X, you know, said this positive thing about this PR and coworker Y that I spent some time teaching said this was increased productivity five X for a week or something, that is like the best stuff
经理们想看到的。嗯，特别是当，这取决于你做什么，对吧？就像如果你是一个只写代码的人，你可以说，看，去看看代码，源代码，就像你可以看到我所有的签入，就像那是，这是我做的所有工作，我一半的工作不是打代码，所以我需要能够说，你做了什么，即使，即使每天的站会，在站会上，我说我认为我今天要做什么。然后我知道那不是会发生的事情，因为其他事情会发生。
that managers wanna see. Well, especially when, it depends what you do, right? Like if you are someone who just writes code and you can just say like look go look at the at the code the source code like you can see all my check-ins right like that's just here's all this work i've done half my job is not typing code right so i need to be able to say like what did you do like even even stand-ups every day at stand-up, I say what I think I'm going to be doing today. And then I know that's not what's going to happen because other things are going to happen.
有人会遇到问题。我会去处理那个。所以我不知道我为什么要费心。有时我确实会。我只是说，你们知道我说的任何话都是谎言。所以我打算做这个，我会做别的事情，因为事情就是这样。是的。
Someone's going to have a problem. I'm going to go do that. So I don't know why I bother. And sometimes I do. I just say, you guys know whatever I say is a lie. So I'm going to think of doing this, and I'll do something else because that's the way it goes. Yep.
总会有人有意见的。我打算去做了。所以我不知道我为什么还要费心。有时候我会这么做。我只是说，你们知道我说的任何话都是谎言。所以我打算做这个，但我会做点别的，因为事情就是这样。没错。
All right. Any last parting C++ now 2021 words? Oh yeah. And also I said, Ben, I cut you off, Tony. I just said, Ben didn't give a talk. He did give a lightning talk on four CCs. Oh, I did. I'm not going to give another one. Yeah. Featured the guinea pig, one of his four guinea pigs named Iota, which obviously everybody should love that name. And apparently you're giving another one. You've already heard Tony's giving a –
好的。还有什么关于 C++ Now 2021 的临别赠言吗？哦，对了。还有，本，我刚才打断你了，托尼。我只是说，本没有做演讲。他确实做了一个关于四个 CC 的闪电演讲。哦，我做了。我不会再做一个了。是的。主角是那只豚鼠，他四只豚鼠中的一只，名叫 Iota，显然每个人都应该喜欢这个名字。而且显然你要再做一个。你已经听说托尼要——
Maybe. Do you know what the name of your lightning talk is, Tony? And Ben? Oh, mine is When Paradigms Collide. Ooh, maybe APL is going to get mentioned. I have to, I'm like, I'm under the wire here. I've got like an hour to make slides on it. I haven't even like put it in.
也许吧。你知道你的闪电演讲叫什么名字吗，托尼？还有本？哦，我的是《当范式碰撞时》。噢，也许 APL 会被提到。我必须得做，我快没时间了。我大概只有一个小时来做幻灯片。我甚至还没把它放进去。
I mentioned to Michael that I might have a talk. I haven't formally put it in there, but yeah, we'll see. See, you have to leave it as, well, I already told you it's complecting made easy. That's what it's going to be called if I ever get to it. If I don't get to it now, I'll do it next conference. And here's the final parting words. You know, Tony gave a secret short lightning talk yesterday at the aforementioned conversation where we missed Barry's talk,
我跟迈克尔提过我可能有个演讲。我还没正式提交，但好吧，走着瞧。你看，你得把它留着，好吧，我已经告诉过你了，叫《让复杂变得简单》。如果我能做的话，它就叫这个名字。如果我现在做不了，我就在下次会议上做。这是最后的临别赠言。你知道，托尼昨天在上述提到的谈话中做了一个秘密的简短闪电演讲，当时我们错过了巴里的演讲，
where he showed his Fabio long hair from I'm not sure what year. I'm sure that was just a couple weeks ago. A couple weeks ago. It wasn't 20, 30 years ago. 25 years ago. No, this is my COVID look. Maybe it's just too easy to type. That's the ultimate thing.
他在那里展示了他不知道是哪一年的法比奥长发造型。我敢肯定那只是几周前的事。几周前。不是 20、30 年前。25 年前。不，这是我的新冠造型。也许只是因为太容易输入了。那是终极原因。
It's too easy to type anything, add a variable, add a function parameter. Even writing code inside I already just wrote add a member function is easier than starting a new file. That's why you make
输入任何东西都太容易了，添加一个变量，添加一个函数参数。甚至在内部写代码，我刚才写了添加一个成员函数，比开始一个新文件更容易。这就是为什么你要制作
member functions. I get this all the time. People are like, where would I put that function? Do I put it in this file? Do I put it in a separate file? And same thing with, I could just write code here in the function I know I need to change. Instead of adding a function. Instead of adding another function.
成员函数。我经常遇到这种情况。人们会问，我应该把那个函数放在哪里？我应该把它放在这个文件里吗？我应该把它放在单独的文件里吗？同样的情况，我可以直接在我知道需要更改的函数中编写代码。而不是添加一个函数。而不是添加另一个函数。
I've got enough for a talk. Sure. Sounds good. Well, thanks for taking the time to tune in and share your thoughts about the conference. And hopefully 2022, come May, we're all going to be in Aspen. Hopefully. I mean, I've got my vaccine appointment for Sunday.
我已经有足够的素材做一个演讲了。当然。听起来不错。好吧，感谢你们抽出时间收听并分享你们对这次会议的看法。希望 2022 年 5 月到来时，我们都能在阿斯彭相聚。希望如此。我的意思是，我已经预约了周日的疫苗接种。
I just locked it in last night. So the world's hopefully going to be going back to normal. Yeah. My second vaccination is coming up as well. This is going to be so weird. Cause I'm not sure how many people are like me and go back and watch podcasts from like 10 years ago and go from zero to episode 150, but there's going to be people like 10 years from now, you know,
我昨晚刚定下来。所以世界有望恢复正常。是的。我的第二针疫苗也快到了。这会很奇怪。因为我不确定有多少人像我一样，回去看 10 年前的播客，从零开始一直看到第 150 集，但 10 年后肯定会有这样的人，你知道，
a handful of them that are listening to this as well. Oh yeah. I guess there is that crazy virus that really messed things up for a while. Let me just slip in the rest of the political like i there was a point where i was saying even before this covid wasn't we really didn't know what's going on with covid but i was just like i'm not going back to the states like your country's on fire and and like i just i'm just gonna avoid this country but like i'm kind of hoping the this not just covet but other stuff settles down and well i mean i hope it makes not just settles down because you go back to the way it was but you know progress is made uh but yeah for a while i was just like i don't want to go to this
其中少数人也在听这个。哦，是的。我想确实有那个疯狂的病毒，把事情搞得一团糟。让我插一句，关于政治方面，比如我曾经说过，甚至在新冠之前，我们真的不知道新冠是怎么回事，但我当时就想，我不会回美国了，因为你们的国家正处于水深火热之中，我只想避开这个国家，但我有点希望，不仅仅是新冠，还有其他事情能平息下来，我的意思是，我希望这不仅仅是平息，因为你回到了原来的样子，但你知道，取得了进步，但确实，有一段时间我只是想，我不想去这个
your country sucks but it's not so bad it's not Canada, you know, but. All right, on that note, and we appreciate all the American listeners that have tuned in up until this episode. Look forward to the- Move up to Canada. That's an idea. Yeah, we'll start that. Tony was talking about a second Canadian conference after CPP North,
你的国家很糟糕，但也没那么糟，它不是加拿大，你知道，但是。好吧，说到这里，我们感谢所有收听到这一集的美国听众。期待——搬到加拿大去。这是个主意。是的，我们会开始那个计划。托尼在谈论 CPP North 之后的第二个加拿大会议，
which hasn't even started yet. It's going to be like the Muskoka Wilderness. Muskoka plus plus. That's not a bad name. No one will understand that. Oh, is this going to have the – are you going to do a talk, which is also a hike? Oh, that's still a plan for aspen someday
它甚至还没开始呢。它会像马斯科卡荒野一样。Muskoka plus plus。这名字不错。没人会明白的。哦，这会有——你会做一个演讲，同时也是一次徒步旅行吗？哦，那仍然是阿斯彭未来的计划之一
someday i'll do the hike talk i was talking to bryce about that a little while ago he's like we have to really do this instead of just talking about it to be clear this is not uh you know tony with like a a gopro giving a talk while he's hiking it's him giving a talk while everybody's hiking right yeah that's the plan you're breaking up well it's every second word uh my plan is actually you guys go for the the walk and i don't that that that is part of the plan i'm gonna put like little uh markers along the path oh nice for you to discuss that's that's my plan. Oh, wow. That sounds like the problem is like, we can't take,
总有一天我会做那个徒步演讲，我前段时间和布莱斯谈过这个，他说我们必须真正去做，而不是只谈论它。澄清一下，这不是托尼带着 GoPro 在徒步时做演讲，而是他在大家徒步时做演讲，对吧？是的，这就是计划。你的声音断断续续的。好吧，是每隔一个词。我的计划其实是你们去散步，而我不去，那确实是计划的一部分，我会在小路上放一些小标记，哦，很高兴你能讨论这个，这就是我的计划。哦，哇。听起来问题在于，我们不能带，
we can't take 60 people or whatever together and do a talk in, you know, cause cause the past too, too narrow, you know, so you have to break up into smaller groups. So we need a way that each group on its own can experience the talk but you know and and we need to i think line the route with like cpp cones yeah exactly that is that you're you've got it that's what it's going to be um and and i might need i need uh you know uh group group leaders right so i might you know hook you guys in to be like okay you're taking one group of 10 and you you go this way you take another group of 10 you go that way and i'll just hang out at the yeah at the barbecue or something wait for you to come back this sounds like a whole new
我们不能带 60 个人或无论多少人一起做一个演讲，你知道，因为路太窄了，所以你必须分成小组。所以我们需要一种方式，让每个小组都能独自体验这个演讲，而且我们需要，我认为需要在路线上排满 C++ 锥形路标，是的，完全正确，这就是你，你抓住了重点，这就是它将要成为的样子，而且我可能需要，我需要，你知道，小组组长，所以我可能会把你们拉进来，说，好吧，你带一组 10 个人，你走这边，你带另一组 10 个人，你走那边，我就在烧烤架那里等着你们回来，这听起来像是一个全新的
category of you know this is gonna be it's gonna start in c++ utopia and then it's gonna spread to every other language yeah yeah That's a good idea. I look forward to it. All right, we'll have to make it happen. All right, 2022. Now you've locked it. This is going out into the ether. People are going to hear it
类别，你知道，这将是，它将从 C++ 乌托邦开始，然后它将传播到每一种其他语言。是的，是的。这是个好主意。我很期待。好吧，我们必须实现它。好吧，2022 年。现在你已经锁定了。这要传到以太网里了。人们会听到的，
and they're going to be disappointed if it doesn't happen. All right, we'll make it happen. We'll make it happen. We could save it for the Muskokas. You start putting a conference together, Tony, and I'll be the first one to sign up. I can't even organize.
如果它没有发生，他们会感到失望的。好吧，我们会让它发生的。我们会让它发生的。我们可以把它留给马斯科卡。你开始组织一个会议吧，托尼，我会是第一个报名的。我甚至无法组织。
I'm supposed to do talks at work every second Monday. I can't get that organized. So don't expect me to be doing a conference. You do a conference, I'll show up. All right. That's how much I'll do. I'll think about Muskoka++. Although, you know, if I end up setting up a conference, you know, like there's going to be an APL dedicated track.
我应该每隔一个周一在工作中做演讲。我无法组织好那个。所以别指望我来组织会议。你组织会议，我就出现。好吧。这就是我能做的。我会考虑 Muskoka++ 的。虽然，你知道，如果我最终组织了一个会议，你知道，肯定会有一个专门的 APL 轨道。
Yeah. See, if it's got nature involved, I will learn APL just for that. Wow. Maybe that's the angle. I'll make APL great again by, you know, bringing nature into the mix somehow. Yep. All right.
是的。你看，如果它涉及到大自然，我会为了那个去学习 APL。哇。也许这就是切入点。我会通过某种方式将大自然融入其中，让 APL 再次伟大。是的。好吧。
This is for the third or fourth time uh thanks for coming on this was awesome thanks connor thanks for listening and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是第三次还是第四次了，感谢你们的到来，这太棒了，谢谢康纳，感谢收听，祝你们有愉快的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。